- Yaël Braun-Pivet: L'ordre du
jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement.
La première d'entre elles va être
posée par le président Laurent
Marcangeli.
- Laurent Marcangeli: Madame la
présidente, merci.
Madame la Première ministre, la
nouvelle vague est là et elle
n'est pas seule.
Avec 48.000 nouveaux cas de Covid
cette semaine, l'épidémie de
bronchiolite se répand sur le
territoire et le démarrage précoce
de celle de la grippe.
Les indicateurs sont au rouge.
Les passages aux urgences
atteignent un niveau inédit depuis
10 ans, ce qui suscite
l'inquiétude légitime de nombreux
parents.
Ces chiffres laissent entrevoir
une hausse des hospitalisations
pendant la période de Noël, déjà
particulièrement tendue.
Nous vivons en parallèle une
situation dramatique sur notre
territoire.
Les services d'urgence ferment,
des départs à la retraite, des
postes vacants...
Des milliers de Français
n'arrivent plus à avoir des soins
près de chez eux, entretenant une
spirale de saturation dont nous
peinons à sortir.
En juillet dernier, le ministre de
la Santé avait pris le sujet à
bras-le-corps pour répondre à la
saturation.
Face à la crise pédiatrique dont
nous parlions dans cet hémicycle
il y a quelques semaines,
certaines de ces mesures ont été
reprises en plus du blocage de
l'enveloppe dédiée.
Le gouvernement a par ailleurs
annoncé l'investissement de plus
de 500 millions d'euros
supplémentaires afin de prendre en
charge les malades correctement
dans les établissements de santé.
Nous saluons ce choix.
Madame la Première ministre, face
à cette nouvelle donne critique,
pourriez-vous indiquer à la
représentation nationale quelles
sont les mesures que le
gouvernement compte mettre en
oeuvre pour faire face à cette
situation et permettre à nos
concitoyens de passer leurs fêtes
de fin d'année le plus sereinement
possible?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame la
Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Monsieur le
président Marcangeli, vous avez
raison de le dire et de tirer la
sonnette d'alarme.
Aujourd'hui, l'épidémie de Covid
repart avec plus de 40.000 cas
détectés par jour, une progression
de près de 10% des
hospitalisations sur une semaine,
une hausse de 22% des
hospitalisations en soins
critiques et 400 décès la semaine
passée.
Cette nouvelle vague nous le
rappelle, le virus n'a pas
disparu.
L'épidémie frappe encore, tue
encore.
Si je fais ce rappel aujourd'hui,
c'est parce que notre hôpital va
encore faire face à une pression
supplémentaire.
A la reprise du Covid-19 s'ajoute
une épidémie de bronchiolite, la
plus virulente depuis 10 ans.
S'ajoute également une épidémie de
grippe saisonnière
particulièrement virulente cette
année, avec cinq régions en phase
épidémique et des premiers effets
sur notre hôpital.
Des mesures ont été prises,
notamment le déclenchement d'un
plan pour mobiliser l'ensemble des
personnels et accroître les
capacités de prise en charge,
ainsi que la mobilisation des ARS
et des préfets pour coordonner les
acteurs.
Je veux rendre hommage au travail
exceptionnel de nos soignants.
Ils se battent pour les malades,
ils se battent contre l'épidémie.
Leur engagement est exceptionnel.
Notre devoir est de les aider, pas
de prendre des mesures purement
idéologiques, qui rendraient leur
mission plus difficile encore.
Aider nos soignants, c'est être
vigilant ensemble.
Je lance un appel solennel.
Respectons les gestes barrières.
Portons le masque dès lors que
nous sommes avec des personnes
fragiles ou dans des zones de
promiscuité, comme les transports
en commun.
Ce sont des petits gestes qui
sauvent des vies, ils sont
décisifs pour faire reculer
l'épidémie.
Les Français ont toujours répondu
à l'appel de la responsabilité.
Je n'ai aucun doute qu'ils le
feront de nouveau.
Aider nos soignants, c'est la
vaccination.
La vaccination contre la grippe,
qui peut être déterminante et qui
est malheureusement très basse
cette année.
Et la vaccination contre le
Covid-19, dont nous savons avec
certitude qu'elle sauve des vies.
Depuis octobre, une campagne de
vaccination pour rappel de vaccin
a été lancée pour les personnes de
plus de 60 ans, personnes fragiles
et bien sûr les soignants.
Seuls 10% de la population cible
ont effectué leur rappel.
C'est bien trop peu.
Je le redis: vaccinez-vous, cela
vous protège et cela protège notre
hôpital.
Aider nos soignants, c'est
défendre la science, défendre
notre système de santé et ne pas
prendre des décisions qui les
mettraient en danger.
J'assume de défendre notre système
de soins.
J'assume de refuser de faire
passer les manoeuvres politiques
avant la science.
J'assume de ne pas soutenir des
mesures démagogiques que les
soignants nous demandent de
rejeter.
J'ai entendu ces derniers jours
des propos terrifiants sur les
vaccins, dont certains confinent à
l'obscurantisme.
Je ne pensais pas dans le pays de
Pasteur, dire qu'on a confiance
dans la parole de nos
scientifiques, que ça prêterait à
des débats aussi vifs.
Nous serons toujours aux côtés des
soignants et des malades.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Michèle
Martinez.
- Michèle Martinez: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie.
Les intoxications au monoxyde de
carbone se multiplient dans cette
période.
Une multiplication de ces
accidents est à craindre avec la
précarité énergétique.
Les Français craignent les
coupures et les factures.
Ces dernières les poussent à
mettre leur vie en danger avec des
moyens de chauffage inadaptés.
Qui aurait pu imaginer que la
France finisse dans cet état?
La France, qui aurait pu être
fière de son indépendance
énergétique, se retrouve dans une
situation accablante en important
plus d'électricité qu'elle n'en
exporte.
Sous notre pression, vous avez
accordé une aide modeste aux
familles qui se chauffent au bois.
C'est insuffisant.
Les Français payent le prix de
votre incompétence.
Depuis François Hollande, vous
échangez les voix des écologistes
contre une politique énergétique
suicidaire.
Abandon du nucléaire, notamment.
Ca nous pousse à sponsoriser la
politique énergétique de
l'Allemagne.
Vous promettez une réforme du prix
de l'électricité, c'est un échec.
Nous avons raison.
Vous êtes incapables de défendre
les Français alors qu'il suffit de
sortir du marché européen.
Que compte faire le gouvernement
pour redonner à la France
l'indépendance énergétique qui
permettra à ses citoyens de se
chauffer décemment?
Pouvez-vous garantir que les
Français ne subiront pas de
coupures d'électricité cet hiver?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Agnès Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Madame la députée Michèle
Martinez, merci de me donner
l'occasion d'éclairer notre
politique énergétique, car
contrairement à ce que vous
indiquez, cette politique a déjà
fait ses preuves pour protéger les
Français.
Protéger les Français, c'est être
le pays qui amortit le plus le
coût de l'augmentation de
l'énergie sur le portefeuille des
Français, avec le bouclier
électricité et le bouclier gaz.
Avec, aussi, les dispositions
prises au niveau du ministère de
l'Economie pour accompagner les
entreprises et donc, sécuriser les
emplois.
Nous sommes le pays où le niveau
d'inflation est le plus faible
d'Europe.
Ce n'est pas une bonne nouvelle
d'avoir de l'inflation mais
reconnaissons aujourd'hui que ce
gouvernement a pris toutes les
mesures pour protéger les
Français.
C'est également un gouvernement
qui a pris toutes les mesures pour
construire notre indépendance
énergétique, car contrairement à
ce que vous dites, jamais la
France n'a été indépendante
énergétiquement.
Le nucléaire, c'est 20% de notre
énergie totale.
Deux tiers de notre énergie est
importé.
Vous êtes le groupe qui empêche la
France de déployer des énergies
renouvelables avec une opposition
stérile et déconnectée.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Un peu de
silence!
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher:
Reconnaissez que vos solutions
n'ont pas de portée pratique.
Nous sommes au travail sur la
sobriété, sur l'efficacité
énergétique, sur l'accélération du
déploiement des énergies
renouvelables et sur la relance du
programme nucléaire.
Nous avons un programme, nous
protégeons les Français et ils
nous font confiance.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame Michèle
Martinez?
- Michèle Martinez: Pouvez-vous
nous garantir que les Français ne
subiront pas de coupure
d'électricité cet hiver?
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Frédéric Maillot.
- Frédéric Maillot: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre du Logement.
Le bouclier tarifaire a été mis en
place pour les Français dont les
logements sont dotés d'un compte
individuel.
Les factures explosent.
Certains artisans ferment déjà,
les bouchers manifestent devant le
palais Bourbon.
Le bouclier tarifaire laisse de
côté bon nombre de concitoyens,
dont les habitants de La Réunion.
Les habitants de 17 millions de
logements en copropriété, dont 5
millions en logements sociaux,
sont déjà étranglés
financièrement.
La faute aux coûts de charges
collectives, notamment de
chauffage, en augmentation de 150
à 200%, qui ne sont pas couverts
par le bouclier tarifaire.
C'est l'équivalent d'un mois de
ressource qui doit être réglé
avant les fêtes.
Impossible pour un retraité qui
perçoit une pension de 800 euros
ou pour un foyer qui vit avec un
SMIC.
Nous demandons l'égalité pour
tous.
L'égalité entre les personnes qui
vivent dans un logement individuel
et les personnes qui vivent dans
un logement collectif.
L'égalité entre l'Hexagone et
l'outre-mer.
Nous avons fait des propositions.
Nous demandons le prolongement et
l'élargissement du bouclier
tarifaire et du chèque énergie.
Nous demandons l'application d'un
taux de TVA pour le gaz et
l'électricité.
Ainsi que l'amendement du fonds de
solidarité par l'Etat.
Se loger, manger, vivre, la
question est insupportable, les
solutions sont sur la table.
Que voulez-vous faire pour tous
les exclus du bouclier tarifaire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Monsieur le
député Maillot, vous évoquez le
chauffage collectif, ce qui
nécessite pour moi de préciser des
choses simples.
Vous avez raison sur le fait qu'il
y a un dispositif pour les
particuliers: le bouclier
tarifaire.
Nous avions un trou dans la
raquette sur le bouclier collectif
pour le chauffage au gaz, qui a
été réparé dans le décret du 9
avril, étendu jusqu'au 31
décembre.
Le sujet qui reste, c'est le
chauffage collectif à
l'électricité, pour lequel, c'est
une question de jours, avant que
le décret rétroactif soit pris par
ce gouvernement et s'applique à
compter du mois de juillet.
Ce qui veut dire qu'une partie des
avances de charges dont vous
parlez feront l'objet de
régularisations au moment où ce
bouclier s'appliquera de manière
rétroactive.
Vous avez raison d'évoquer les
discussions que nous avons.
C'est avec les bailleurs sociaux,
même s'il y a parfois des
chauffages qui ne sont pas
couverts, que nous avançons sur ce
sujet.
Le deuxième, c'est le chèque
énergie.
Dans un certain nombre de cas,
nous avons des bénéficiaires qui
ne l'utilise pas.
Il faut simplifier.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Maillot?
- Frédéric Maillot: Merci de
reconnaître que j'ai raison, mais
ça n'apporte pas de réponse aux
boulangers et aux bouchers qui
ferment leurs boutiques.
Il faut leur donner raison aussi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Stéphane Vojetta...
Monsieur le ministre,
excusez-moi...
Vous avez quelques secondes.
- Christophe Béchu: Monsieur le
député, merci de reconnaître que
la réponse que je vous ai faite
vous satisfait sur un point.
Vous ne m'interrogez que sur une
partie des questions.
Pour les personnes dont vous
parliez, c'est l'amortisseur qui
prend le relais, nous prendrons en
charge une partie du surcoût.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Stéphane Vojetta.
- Stéphane Vojetta: Ma question
s'adresse également à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
Monsieur le ministre, prenez
quelques instants pour imaginer la
scène.
Vous rentrez chez vous ce soir,
vous mettez la clé dans la serrure
de votre domicile et vous réalisez
que celle-ci a été modifiée.
Rapidement, vous devez vous rendre
à l'évidence.
Quelqu'un a pris possession de
votre logement: un squatter.
Face à cette situation, nous avons
agi, en renforçant la procédure
d'expulsion expresse.
Grâce à cette procédure, 170
victimes ont pu récupérer leur
domicile.
Il n'est pas normal qu'un
propriétaire qui sort un squatter
de sa
propriété ait une sanction plus
lourde que le squatter.
Nous devons agir sur la situation
des propriétaires dont les
locataires ne payent plus de
loyer.
Je pense à un couple qui vit dans
une caravane.
Leur appartement est occupé par
une locataire qui ne paye plus ses
loyers depuis deux ans.
Nous ne pouvons pas accepter que
les procédures s'étendent jusqu'à
cinq ans.
Il faut agir.
Non pas pour permettre à de riches
Thénardier de martyriser de
pauvres Jean Valjean, mais bien
pour aider les propriétaires qui
sont poussés dans la précarité.
Nous discuterons de ces
propositions de loi.
Un texte attendu par les Français
et une cause qui devrait
rassembler la représentation
nationale bien au-delà de cette
majorité.
Pouvez-vous nous expliquer dans
quelle mesure cette proposition
permet d'améliorer le marché
locatif, en protégeant toutes les
victimes d'abus, propriétaires ou
locataires, mises en difficulté?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
présidente, monsieur le député
Vojetta.
Votre question est
particulièrement d'actualité car
la proposition de loi a commencé à
être examinée hier.
Sécuriser les propriétaires, c'est
s'assurer qu'on ne se retrouve pas
avec des demandes de garanties qui
ne cessent d'augmenter, avec des
refus de louer qui viendraient
tendre un peu plus le marché
locatif, pour vous répondre de
manière directe.
Vous avez cité un cas.
Il en a malheureusement trop, ce
sont des cas qui frappent
l'opinion publique et qui montre
que nous avons, malgré les
modifications législatives, un
équilibre qui n'est pas atteint
entre le droit des propriétaires
et ce droit au logement, qui
conduit à se retrouver dans des
situations où on inverse la charge
de la responsabilité sur les
propriétaires qui n'en demandaient
pas tant.
Pour autant, votre proposition de
loi, qui a le mérite d'être large,
ne fait pas l'impasse sur des
sujets compliqués.
Elle va au-delà du problème dont
nous parlions.
Pour s'assurer que
nous avons le point de vigilance
du gouvernement, c'est de soutenir
pleinement la nécessité d'être
ferme avec les squatters, de
modifier les équilibres qui
existent et d'être capables de
distinguer les locataires de bonne
ou de mauvaise foi.
Il ne faudrait pas qu'à partir de
cette proposition de loi, nous
n'arrivions pas à trouver un
équilibre auquel nous sommes
attachés, qui consiste réellement
à défendre les propriétaires, sans
englober des gens qui sont dans
des situations humaines complexes
et douloureuses, et qui ne doivent
pas être emportés, sous couvert
d'une vision de mauvaise foi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur le
président Bertrand Pancher.
- Bertrand Pancher: Madame la
Première ministre, nos jeunes sont
en quête d'espérance.
Nos aînés sont abandonnés.
Les plus riches continuent à
s'enrichir.
La classe moyenne s'appauvrit.
Quant aux pauvres, ce sont les
grands oubliés.
Je veux vous faire part de ma
grande inquiétude sur les
profondes inégalités dans notre
pays.
Une récente étude de l'INSEE
montre que votre politique fiscale
a surtout profité aux plus riches.
Un homme résume bien ce sentiment:
"On tape sur les plus précaires,
on taxe les chômeurs.
Il y a un problème."
La période de Noël approche.
Combien n'auront rien ou si peu à
se mettre sous le sapin?
Je veux vous parler de la prime de
Noël.
2 millions de Français la
toucheront.
Elle ne sera pas versée aux jeunes
sans ressources ni aux personnes
en situation de handicap.
Ce n'est pas juste.
Je vous demande de l'élargir à
tous les bénéficiaires des minima
sociaux.
Il faut la revaloriser.
Elle ne l'a pas été depuis 2007.
Avec l'inflation, elle doit passer
à 200 euros.
Cette prime, c'est l'urgence.
Qu'allez-vous faire sur le long
terme?
Le grand plan de lutte contre la
pauvreté en 2019?
Repoussé puis abandonné.
Le chèque alimentaire?
Repoussé puis enterré.
Le revenu universel d'activité,
promesse du président, il a été
patiemment balayé.
Votre dispositif de solidarité à
la source pour lutter contre le
non-recours aux prestations
sociales connaîtra-t-il le même
sort?
Vous annoncez des premières
expérimentations en 2023.
Faisons très vite, madame la
Première ministre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame la
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le président Bertrand
Pancher.
L'une de nos grandes batailles,
c'est l'égalité des chances.
La lutte contre la pauvreté est au
coeur de l'égalité des chances.
Nous agissons de manière résolue,
déterminée, notamment grâce à la
stratégie Pauvreté 2018-2022.
Cette stratégie, ce sont des
actions directes, concrètes, pour
permettre aux familles précaires
d'avoir un toit, de se soigner, de
garantir une alimentation
suffisante et équilibrée à leurs
enfants.
Nous voulons agir directement sur
la pauvreté, en répondant aux
problèmes quotidiens.
Notre stratégie, c'est aussi une
action pour l'égalité des chances
pour notre jeunesse.
Je pense aux plus de 100.000
élèves qui bénéficient des repas à
la cantine à moins d'un euro.
Je pense à la création des centres
et maisons participatifs.
Ou encore, au déploiement des
accueils de proximité qui couvrent
plus de 90% du territoire.
Ce sujet appelle à l'humilité.
Le taux de pauvreté n'a pas
augmenté depuis la crise
sanitaire.
Le nombre d'allocataires du RSA
diminue depuis novembre 2020.
Il est repassé sous son niveau de
janvier 2017.
Aujourd'hui, nous devons amplifier
nos efforts.
La stratégie Pauvreté 2018-2022
arrive à son terme et nous avons
initié les travaux avec les
collectivités et les associations
pour préparer la suite.
Cela se concrétisera par un pacte
des solidarités, structuré autour
de quatre axes: la lutte contre
les inégalités à la racine, le
retour à l'activité, clé d'une
sortie durable de la pauvreté, le
refus de se résigner à la grande
marginalité et la transition
écologique solidaire.
Nous préparons l'avenir.
Il nous faut aussi traiter
l'urgence.
L'inflation appelle une réponse
forte, et rapide, surtout pour les
plus fragiles.
C'est pour ça que nous avons
décidé de revaloriser de manière
anticipée les prestations sociales
à hauteur de 4%.
C'est pour ça que nous avons pris
les mesures les plus protectrices
pour limiter les prix du gaz et de
l'électricité.
Nous avons revalorisé de 50%
l'allocation de soutien familial
pour les parents qui élèvent seuls
leurs enfants.
C'est pour ça que nous avons mis
en place une aide exceptionnelle
de solidarité qui a bénéficié à 11
millions de personnes.
Le 15 décembre prochain, nous
verserons de manière automatique
la prime de Noël à plus de 2
millions de ménages, notamment les
bénéficiaires du RSA ou de
l'allocation spécifique de
solidarité.
C'est 500 millions d'euros.
Cette prime montre notre
engagement constant à accompagner
les personnes qui en ont le plus
besoin.
Nous ne laisserons personne sur le
bord du chemin.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur le président Olivier
Marleix.
- Olivier Marleix: Le premier
quinquennat du président Emmanuel
Macron a été marqué par de
nombreux renoncements par rapport
à notre souveraineté industrielle.
Dassault est le dernier fleuron
industriel du pays.
Le prochain projet de l'avion de
combat du futur fait l'objet d'un
bras de fer entre la France et
l'Allemagne, avec en toile de
fond, la question de maîtrise du
savoir-faire industriel.
Ce projet a été plusieurs fois
reporté, notamment parce que le
gouvernement allemand a fait du
partage de notre technologie un
préalable à toute discussion.
Dans un contexte franco-allemand
largement dégradé, je pense au
désaccord sur la gestion de la
crise énergétique, à l'annulation
du Conseil des ministres
franco-allemand, ou à d'autres
projets militaires abandonnés, le
gouvernement allemand a communiqué
de manière unilatérale sur la
conclusion d'un accord.
Accord que vous avez vous-même
confirmé lors de votre déplacement
à Berlin vendredi dernier.
Quelques heures après,
l'entreprise Dassault a rappelé
que rien n'était signé.
Madame la Première ministre, où en
est-on par rapport à ce dossier?
Pouvez-vous garantir
solennellement à la représentation
nationale que Dassault sera bien
maître d'oeuvre de l'avion et du
système de combat?
Pouvez-vous assurer que les droits
de propriété intellectuelle ne
seront pas cédés?
Pouvez-vous nous assurer que
Dassault et la France garderont
leur liberté d'action sur
l'exportation de ces avions?
Sans ça, ce serait une soumission
à l'Allemagne, pour sauver la
grande illusion du couple
franco-allemand.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Monsieur le
président Olivier Marleix, la
souveraineté stratégique française
et européenne est déterminante.
Nous la défendons avec force.
Vous m'interrogez sur le système
de combat aérien du futur.
Ce projet ambitieux, lancé en
2017, mené en coopération avec
l'Allemagne et l'Espagne, atteint
une étape importante de son
développement.
Sur la nature du projet, d'abord.
Comme vous le savez, c'est un
système complet.
Un avion de combat associé à des
drones.
C'est un système qui sera
structurant pour nos forces
armées, pour être en mesure d'agir
efficacement sur tout le spectre
des missions aériennes de combat,
y compris la dissuasion.
C'est en marge opérationnelle, à
horizon 2040, notre supériorité
aérienne et notre capacité à
avancer.
La France y est engagée car elle y
trouve son intérêt, avec ses
partenaires allemands et
espagnols.
C'est une coopération majeure.
Elle garantit l'interopérabilité
de nos forces.
Elle renforce la souveraineté
européenne, tout en préservant nos
intérêts stratégiques, industriels
et technologiques.
L'appui du gouvernement et de nos
partenaires à ce projet est total.
Nos trois pays ont récemment
réaffirmé leur détermination à
aller de l'avant.
Le président de la République s'y
est investi.
C'est un grand pas.
Dans le contexte international
actuel, c'est un signal important
de l'excellente coopération entre
nos nations.
Le chancelier allemand, avec
lequel j'ai pu m'entretenir
vendredi dernier, a lui-même
marqué son attachement au projet
et sa confiance dans une
conclusion rapide.
L'impulsion et la volonté
politique sont là.
Vous m'interrogez plus
spécifiquement sur les enjeux
industriels de ce projet.
Avec le ministre des Armées, nous
y sommes particulièrement
attentifs.
Nous nous engageons aujourd'hui
dans une nouvelle phase du projet,
la réalisation du démonstrateur,
avant les phases de développement
et de production.
Après plus d'un an de discussions
sur ce programme complexe, les
positions des industriels
convergent.
Nous sommes dans la période de
finalisation des contrats.
Nous nous assurons de la cohérence
de ce programme avec nos intérêts
stratégiques.
Notre capacité à exporter est un
des critères fondamentaux, il est
connu de nos partenaires.
La soutenabilité financière est
un prérequis.
Nous ne transiterons pas.
Nous construisons avec nos
industriels et nous ne
transigerons pas.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Brigitte Liso.
- Brigitte Liso: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la ministre Agnès Firmin Le
Bodo, ce 1er décembre marque la
journée de lutte contre le sida.
Nous pouvons tous porter un
message espoir.
La France pourrait être le premier
pays à voir la fin de la
contamination au VIH d'ici 2027.
C'est notre législature qui va
atteindre cet objectif, après 40
ans de drames et de vies brisées.
Tous les spécialistes sont
unanimes.
Nous en avons les moyens, grâce
aux progrès considérables des
traitements et à la prise en
charge des patients.
Nous n'y arriverons pas sans
prendre des mesures fortes,
notamment sur le dépistage chez
les jeunes.
Les chiffres sont alarmants.
13% de nouveaux cas sont des
jeunes de moins de 25 ans.
Près de 28% des séropositifs sont
diagnostiqués avec une infection
avancée.
La faute à la crise?
Pas seulement.
Depuis plusieurs années, le sida
ne fait plus peur.
On entend souvent dire qu'on peut
vivre avec, qu'il existe des
traitements...
Soyons clairs.
Le sida tue encore et toujours.
Chers collègues, ce combat est le
combat de tous.
Chacun d'entre nous, dans chacune
de nos circonscriptions, passons
ce message simple: le dépistage du
VIH est gratuit et sans
ordonnance.
Soutenons nos associations.
Participons à des actions de
sensibilisation.
Parlons sans tabou, dans les
écoles, les collèges et les
lycées.
Nous devons ce combat à toutes les
personnes qui nous ont quittées.
"Quelqu'un de dépisté, c'est
quelqu'un de soigné, qui ne
transmet plus la maladie."
Madame la ministre,
qu'envisagez-vous pour
sensibiliser la population à ce
risque?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Agnès Firmin Le Bodo.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo: Madame la
députée Brigitte Liso, votre
question est essentielle, à
l'avant-veille de la journée
mondiale contre le sida, et que
les chiffres montrent que le
nombre de personnes se découvrant
séropositives reste stable.
Oui, le sida tue encore et
toujours.
Le gouvernement entend approfondir
les efforts pour améliorer la
prévention, le dépistage et le
traitement du VIH, à travers la
nouvelle feuille de route.
La généralisation, depuis cette
année, au dépistage sérologique
sans prescription, est prise en
charge à 100%, notamment.
Nous allons renforcer notre
stratégie globale.
Elle repose sur le préservatif, le
dépistage du VIH, leur traitement,
le traitement après exposition et
le traitement après exposition.
Depuis 2021, un premier pas a été
franchi, avec l'ouverture de la
primo prescription à tout médecin,
afin de favoriser un recours à ce
dispositif.
L'accessibilité à ce traitement a
été accélérée, avec une délivrance
sous forme de kit par les médecins
généralistes.
Elle sera renforcée avec une
ouverture aux pharmaciens.
Nous avançons vers une plus grande
accélération des tests VIH.
Ce modèle, lancé depuis 11 ans, a
démontré tout son intérêt.
Il faut en améliorer la
flexibilité.
Le Covid-19 nous a rappelés que la
lutte contre les pandémies doit
faire appel à une lutte sur tous
les bords.
La France va verser plus d'un
milliard d'euros au Fonds mondial
de lutte contre le sida,
tuberculose et le paludisme, pour
réaffirmer l'objectif d'un monde
sans sida à l'horizon 2030.
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Julien
Rancoule pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Julien Rancoule: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre de
l'Intérieur.
Dans la nuit du 27 au 28 octobre,
un multirécidiviste étranger
s'introduisait dans l'hôpital
Cochin et violait une patiente.
Cet homme avait reçu trois
demandes de quitter le territoire.
Il avait déjà été suspecté de viol
sur mineure en 2020.
Que fait encore cet homme en
France?
En 2019, Emmanuel Macron annonçait
vouloir porter à 100 % le taux
d'exécution des obligations de
quitter le territoire.
Vous avez affirmé que le
gouvernement voulait durcir les
obligations de quitter le
territoire.
Les Français veulent des actes.
Le taux d'exécution des
obligations de quitter le
territoire n'a jamais été aussi
faible.
Aujourd'hui encore, l'une de nos
compatriotes paie le prix de votre
laxisme.
Pourtant, comme l'a proposé Marine
Le Pen, il existe des moyens de
pression à fin d'obtenir les
laissez-passer des consulats.
Quand comptez-vous agir?
Dernièrement, vous avez proposé la
création d'un nouveau titre de
séjour visant à régulariser les
clandestins irrégulièrement
présents sur notre territoire.
Vous semblez particulièrement
ingénieux pour faire entrer des
étrangers sur notre sol mais
beaucoup moins pour renvoyer ceux
qui pourrissent la vie des
Français.
Quand allez-vous faire exécuter
toutes les obligations de quitter
le territoire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame la ministre, Dominique
Faure.
- Dominique Faure: Les
frontières ont été fermées pour
des mesures sanitaires.
Nous faisons mieux que nos voisins
européens.
Nous avons procédé à plus de
11.000 mesures d'éloignement en
2021.
En 2022, les éloignements sont en
hausse de 20 % par rapport à 2021.
Depuis 2017, nous avons expulsé
plus de 700 étrangers radicalisés.
Notre priorité est d'expulser les
étrangers délinquants.
3500 étrangers constituent une
menace pour l'ordre public, ils
ont été éloignés du territoire
français depuis 2020.
88.000 titres de séjour ont été
refusés ou retirés pour motif
d'ordre public.
Le ministère de l'Intérieur a
donné des instructions très
claires aux préfets via une
instruction du 17 novembre 2020:
les étrangers sous obligation de
quitter le territoire seront
inscrits au fichier des personnes
recherchées.
Nous devons aller encore plus
loin.
Le gouvernement aura ainsi
l'occasion de formuler ses
propositions pour mieux lutter
encore contre l'immigration
irrégulière, à l'occasion du
prochain débat sur l'immigration
au Parlement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Julien Rancoule: Vous ne
répondez pas.
Que faisait encore cet homme en
France?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Sylvain
Carrière, pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Sylvain Carrière: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
2022 en France, c'est plus 10% sur
l'alimentation, plus 15% sur les
produits alimentaires essentiels,
plus 15% pour l'électricité et
seulement 5% pour le SMIC.
Nous avons proposé le SMIC à 1600
euros, vous l'avez refusé.
Nous proposons le blocage des
prix, vous refusez encore.
En macronie, se chauffer ou
manger, il faut choisir.
10 millions de Français sous le
seuil de pauvreté selon le Secours
populaire.
Voilà le vrai bilan de votre
politique.
Une personne sur quatre accueillie
dans les banques alimentaires a
moins de 25 ans.
83% des étudiants qui fréquentent
l'aide alimentaire ont commencé
depuis mars 2020.
A Montpellier, en novembre, 1000
étudiants en ont profité.
Vous annoncez des repas du CROUS à
un euro.
Mais les étudiants se retrouvent
avec du pain industriel, trois
morceaux de salade et deux miettes
de poulet.
Les miettes, miroir de la société,
du ruissellement d'une élite qui
se gave, d'une élite qui refuse
l'ISS, qui défend le patron de
Total qui se félicite de gagner 6
millions d'euros en 2021.
En même temps, des parents doivent
rationner leurs propres enfants.
Des technocrates autour d'une
table se permettent de décider
l'aide qui convient à ceux qui
font la queue dans le froid.
Nous ne voulons plus d'aides au
lance-pierre, mais de la dignité
pour les Françaises et les
Français.
Quand allez-vous enfin écouter les
associations qui sont en première
ligne?
L'inflation prévue dans les mois à
venir va atteindre de nouveaux
records.
La France est riche.
Quand allez-vous partager?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Agnès Firmin Le Bodo.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo: Monsieur
le député Sylvain Carrière,
l'inflation et la hausse des prix
de l'énergie ont en effet un
impact sur les associations de
l'aide alimentaire et auprès de 4
millions de bénéficiaires.
Les banques alimentaires font
remonter leur inquiétude et le
gouvernement agit.
La première loi de finances
rectificatives comportait ainsi
une enveloppe de 55 millions
d'euros, en plus des 56 millions
d'euros de la loi de finances
initiale.
Cette enveloppe a permis de
protéger les associations
fragilisées par la hausse des prix
des denrées.
J'ajoute qu'un travail est en
cours pour changer les modalités
de passation des marchés afin de
réduire la complexité et les
risques qui pèsent sur les
acteurs.
Une seconde enveloppe
exceptionnelle de 40 millions
d'euros supplémentaires a été
dégagée dans la seconde loi de
finances votée il y a peu.
Ces fonds seront mobilisés pour
lutter contre la précarité
étudiante.
10 millions d'euros seront dédiés
au financement d'au moins 300.000
colis alimentaires, permettant à
un étudiant de se nourrir pendant
trois semaines.
Je rappelle que les banques
alimentaires bénéficient bien
évidemment du bouclier tarifaire.
Enfin, au-delà des crédits
d'urgence mobilisés, l'action du
gouvernement en faveur de l'aide
alimentaire prend la forme d'un
fonds pour une aide alimentaire
durable, doté de 60 millions
d'euros pour 2023, afin de
renforcer la qualité de l'aide
alimentaire et de soutenir des
projets locaux innovants.
Le gouvernement agit, vous le
voyez.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Marina
Ferrari pour le groupe démocrate.
- Marina Ferrari: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur Christophe
Béchu, ministre de la Transition
écologique et de la Transition des
Territoires.
Le 22 novembre, vous avez annoncé
la mise en place d'un temps de
formation et de sensibilisation à
destination des élus locaux sur
les questions de transition
écologique.
Le groupe Modem et Indépendants
salue cette mesure.
Les collectivités locales sont en
effet en première ligne pour
engager les chantiers pour
accélérer la transition
écologique.
Les agences du ministère seraient
chargées de ces formations.
Quels moyens et quelles ressources
humaines pourraient être alloués à
ces agences pour remplir cette
mission?
Vous avez annoncé que la formation
concernait les conséquences d'une
dérèglement climatique, territoire
par territoire.
Nos élus locaux rencontrent de
véritables difficultés pour
appréhender les enjeux liés au
développement des énergies
renouvelables.
De nombreux sujets sont cruciaux.
A ce titre, il me semblerait
important que les volets
développement et gestion de l'eau
soient intégrés à ces formations.
Il faut donner les clés pour
éviter de tomber dans certains
écueils et s'assurer de la
réussite des projets développés.
Concernant le financement de ces
formations, pouvez-vous nous
préciser s'il viendra émarger sur
l'enveloppe dédiée au fonds vert?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: J'ai eu
l'occasion d'indiquer notre
volonté de lancer une formation,
partout en France, à destination
de tous les maires, précisément
autour de ces questions du
dérèglement climatique et de la
préservation de la biodiversité.
On s'est basé sur un département
de ce pays, le département de
l'Indre.
241 communes.
250 élus ont suivi une formation
organisée par la préfecture, avec
l'appui du département, et qui
s'est appuyée sur les forces vives
du ministère: des agents de Météo
France, par exemple.
On a par exemple 35 intervenants
climat au sein de Météo France.
Les maires qui ont décidé de
suivre ces sessions de formation,
on leur a démontré ce qu'étaient
les conséquences du changement
climatique sur le territoire.
On a fait témoigner des élus qui
s'étaient lancés dans des
politiques d'îlots de fraîcheur,
par exemple.
On a fait l'expérience d'une
politique du concret.
Au-delà de ces questions sur
l'adaptation, sur la biodiversité,
on veut répondre aux questions qui
sont en train de monter: par
exemple, la question de l'eau.
L'autre sujet, c'était les
énergies renouvelables.
On a un enjeu de pédagogie.
Il faut être capable de regarder
la manière dont on peut avancer,
mesurer les freins et construire
des consensus locaux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Alain
David pour le groupe socialiste.
- Alain David: Monsieur le
ministre de l'Economie et des
Finances, un mouvement de grève
d'ampleur touche plusieurs sites
de l'entreprise Sanofi, dont un
près de Bordeaux.
Ce mouvement de grève a été
reconduit au sein des sites
Sanofi, dont une partie des
personnels réclame toujours des
revalorisations salariales, ainsi
que la titularisation des deux
tiers des contrats précaires.
En 10 ans, Sanofi a perçu plus
d'un milliard d'euros d'aides
publiques de l'Etat.
Ce sujet est donc au carrefour de
plusieurs problématiques
préoccupantes.
La pénurie de certains médicaments
et les superprofits, entre autres.
Sanofi est dans une logique
financière malsaine.
Au lieu de se concentrer sur son
métier de recherche et de
production de médicaments, elle
avait déjà choqué en poursuivant
les licenciements alors qu'elle
réalise des profits importants.
A l'été 2022, l'annonce de la
fermeture d'un site de recherche
et de développement, avec 1600
emplois, avait créé la surprise.
Avant cela, un autre site avait
été fermé.
De la même manière, pendant cette
crise sanitaire, des grands
espoirs avaient été placés, avant
d'être cruellement déçus, dans la
capacité de l'entreprise de
produire un vaccin viable.
Ma question sera donc simple:
quelle contrepartie le
gouvernement entend exiger de
l'entreprise Sanofi en matière de
maintien de l'emploi, de juste
répartition des profits envers les
salariés et d'investissement dans
la recherche et la production des
médicaments dont notre pays a
cruellement besoin?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Roland Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Vous
m'interrogez
sur un conflit qui affecte
aujourd'hui une partie de
l'entreprise Sanofi, y compris au
sujet des salaires.
Je voudrais commencer par rappeler
à l'Assemblée nationale une étude
publiée aujourd'hui, qui dit que
la France est le meilleur élève du
pouvoir d'achat en Europe.
Entre 2019 et 2022, le pouvoir
d'achat en France a augmenté.
Il a augmenté de 1,5 % alors qu'il
stagnait en Allemagne et il
baissait en Italie, au Royaume-Uni
et en Espagne.
Grâce aux mesures ayant été votées
par cette majorité, l'inflation
est aujourd'hui plus basse en
France qu'elle ne l'est nulle part
ailleurs en Europe.
Grâce aux efforts des entreprises
qui ont continué à créer de
l'emploi, le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés français a progressé.
Faut-il s'arrêter là?
Non.
Cette majorité a voté le
triplement de la prime de partage
de la valeur, cet été.
Plus de 730.000 salariés en ont
bénéficié.
L'intéressement et la
participation, là encore, votés
par cette majorité, c'est 60 % de
bénéficiaires en plus.
Pour les salaires, vous le savez,
Sanofi a proposé une hausse des
rémunérations pour l'ensemble des
salariés en 2023 de plus de 7%.
Une partie en salaire, une partie
en prime.
J'engage les parties de Sanofi à
poursuivre cette négociation, dont
j'espère qu'elle sera conclusive.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Claude Raux pour le groupe
écologiste.
- Jean-Claude Raux: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de la Santé.
J'ai lu dans une tribune du Monde
que la santé mentale était l'enjeu
du 21e siècle.
Pourtant, près de 30% des postes
de psychiatres sont vacants en
France.
Et je n'ose commenter l'état de la
pédopsychiatrie.
Hier, des mots m'ont frappé:
abandon, incompréhension,
épuisement.
Ce sont les mêmes mots qui
résonnent pour chacun de mes
collègues dans tous les
territoires.
En Loire-Atlantique, des médecins
et paramédicaux s'évertuent à
mener un travail et des projets de
qualité.
Les demandes sans fin
d'adaptation, l'accroissement des
missions, les décisions
méprisantes de l'ARS
créent l'épuisement et la
dégradation des soins.
21 patients ont dû être accueillis
cet été dans un hôpital dans la
Sarthe, malgré le sous-effectif
déjà criant.
Les patients rentrent chez eux
après l'hospitalisation sans suivi
approprié.
L'absence de médecins dans
certains territoires pourrait
entraîner d'autres transhumances
de patients dans de mauvaises
conditions.
Certains ne peuvent même pas
accéder aux soins.
Des enfants sont pris en charge
dans les services pour adultes,
faute de places.
Les médecins psychiatriques ne
sont plus capables de penser, ils
naviguent à vue en fonction des
arrêts de travail.
Des équipes entières vous parlent
de guerre au quotidien et ne sont
pas entendues.
Que leur répondez-vous?
Allez-vous enfin faire de la santé
mentale une priorité?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Agnès
Firmin Le Bodo.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo: Monsieur
le député Jean-Claude Raux, la
psychiatrie et plus largement la
prise en charge de la santé
mentale, est un sujet
d'importance, qui fait l'objet de
toute mon attention.
Les conséquences de la crise Covid
ont beaucoup affecté la santé
mentale des Français.
Ce matin ont été reçus au
ministère de la Santé les quatre
syndicats qui ont appelé à la
grève.
Nous avons convenu qu'un cycle de
réunions de travail sur les sujets
propres à la psychiatrie
s'ouvrirait à partir de janvier
avec les représentants de la
profession.
Nous souhaitons pouvoir établir un
plan d'ampleur pour améliorer les
conditions d'exercice et conduire
les chantiers structurels de
modernisation de la profession.
Ces chantiers structurels sont
déjà en cours.
La réforme du financement de la
psychiatrie a pour but de réduire
les inégalités entre les
territoires.
Prochainement sera effectué un
premier bilan des
Assises de la psychiatrie et de la
santé mentale.
L'enjeu du soutien à la
pédopsychiatrie est majeur.
Nous voulons accélérer les actions
dans ce domaine.
En 2020, une enveloppe de 110
millions d'euros a été débloquée.
Dans le cadre du Ségur, des
projets de modernisation des
établissements psychiatriques ont
été mis en place.
Nous voulons développer les
leviers locaux en créant des
alliances auprès des
professionnels du terrain.
Nous activons tous les leviers
pour refonder et transformer notre
système de santé et l'adapter aux
défis auxquels nous faisons face.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Lionel
Vuibert pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Lionel Vuibert: Comme vous le
savez, la crise énergétique que
nous traversons impacte fortement
la trésorerie des entreprises.
Les entreprises, grandes
consommatrices d'énergie, doivent
négocier leurs contrats,
connaissent de réelles
difficultés.
Nombreuses sont les entreprises
qui voient leur équilibre
économique mis en péril.
Dans un environnement conjoncturel
difficile, l'activité continue
néanmoins à résister globalement.
Nous le devons au gouvernement et
à sa majorité, qui ont mesuré
les conséquences de cette
inflation.
110 milliards d'euros d'aides ont
été engagés sur trois ans.
Des modalités de simplification et
de renforcement des différents
dispositifs d'aides aux
d'entreprise ont été présentées
dernièrement.
Parmi les mesures, le bouclier
tarifaire qui permet de plafonner
les factures d'électricité du BTP.
Ou encore, l'amortisseur
électricité.
Ces dispositifs peuvent être
encore améliorés, notamment en ce
qui concerne les entreprises
créées après le 1er décembre 2021.
Monsieur le ministre, quelles
mesures complémentaires pourraient
être mises en oeuvre pour aider
les entreprises en grande
difficulté ou non concernées par
les dispositifs existants?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Roland Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Merci de
m'interroger sur ce secteur
industriel que vous connaissez
bien.
Vous êtes élu d'un département
industriel, les Ardennes.
Vous nous interrogez sur les aides
que nous avons adoptées.
Cela me permet de rappeler que
depuis une dizaine de jours, nous
avons simplifié et prolongé le
dispositif d'aides.
J'engage toutes les entreprises de
France à se connecter sur le site
d'impôts du gouvernement.
Un simulateur vous permet
d'évaluer en temps réel l'aide à
laquelle vous aurez droit en 2022
et en 2023.
J'étais la semaine dernière dans
le Loiret pour visiter un
imprimeur.
Il verra sa facture énergétique
payée à peu près d'un tiers grâce
aux aides en 2022 et sans doute
encore en 2023, si les prix de
l'énergie restent là où ils sont.
Il reste encore sans doute
quelques trous à combler,
notamment les entreprises qui
n'existaient pas en 2021, et pour
lesquelles la facture énergétique
est donc difficile à remplir.
Nous sommes en train de réfléchir
à comment compléter ce dispositif.
Je tiens à rassurer la
représentation nationale.
Nous sommes là pour soutenir notre
industrie, à la fois dans la
transition majeure qui va l'amener
à se décarboner dans les prochaines
années, mais aussi à passer
l'hiver dans les prochains jours.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Damien
Maudet, pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Damien Maudet: En France,
peut-on soigner encore nos
enfants?
S'il faut consulter un pédiatre,
impossible, il n'y en a plus.
S'il faut aller aux urgences, il
n'y a plus de places.
Même pour soigner une angine, il
n'y a plus de médicaments.
Ce que révèle cette pandémie,
c'est qu'il y a des services qui
doivent être placés en dehors des
lois du marché.
Sur nos médicaments, où en
sommes-nous?
Sous votre gouvernement, la
situation ne fait que se dégrader.
On est passé de 400 en 2016 à 2200
pénuries de médicaments en 2021.
Les molécules pour produire ces
médicaments sont faites en Chine
et en Inde.
Les multinationales jugent les
médicaments peu rentables.
Après avoir regardé partir ces
multinationales, vous les gaver
d'argent public en espérant les
faire revenir.
Plus de soignants et maintenant,
plus de médicaments.
Quand allez-vous reprendre la main
pour nos vies, pour notre
industrie?
La logique que vous perpétuez est
une folie.
Pourquoi n'est-on plus capable de
produire une simple boîte
d'amoxicilline?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur Roland Lescure, ministre
en charge de l'Industrie.
Je rappelle à chacun que nous
n'avons pas le droit de brandir
des objets dans l'hémicycle.
Vous le savez très bien.
- Roland Lescure: Monsieur le
député Damien Maudet, vous avez
souhaité, dans votre question,
inquiéter les Françaises et les
Français.
Ca ne me surprend pas.
C'est votre fonds de commerce.
Je voudrais commencer ma réponse
par les rassurer.
Aujourd'hui, nos concitoyens qui
se voient prescrire du paracétamol
ou de l'amoxicilline se voient
délivrer du paracétamol ou de
l'amoxicilline.
Pour autant, existe-t-il des
tensions sur le marché?
La réponse est oui.
Dans le monde entier, depuis
quatre ans, la consommation de
médicaments a été très volatile.
On sait tous pourquoi.
Le gouvernement a réagi très vite
à ces situations de tension.
Nous disposons d'un dispositif
d'alerte unique en France, qui
nous a permis d'être alertés très
tôt, dès le mois de juillet 2022.
Nous avons contingenté les stocks
au niveau des industriels pour
distribuer équitablement les
pharmacies sur le territoire.
Depuis octobre 2022, les
grossistes ne peuvent plus
exporter les médicaments en
question.
Nous avons augmenté la production
de paracétamol en France, avec des
usines qui tournent aujourd'hui 24
heures sur 24 et sept jours sur
sept.
Nous nous sommes assurés que la
distribution serait calée sur le
besoin médical.
Nous travaillons pour améliorer
l'usage des antibiotiques.
Pour autant, nous sommes d'accord
avec vous sur un point: nous
devons renforcer la souveraineté
industrielle française.
Contrairement à vous, nous
agissons.
Nous avons annoncé la
réinstallation de la production
des principes actifs en Isère, non
loin de Grenoble.
Ce projet est en cours.
On devrait avoir des premières
livraisons en 2025.
- Damien Maudet: Aujourd'hui,
c'est vous qui inquiétez les
Français.
Vous leur promettez de continuer
comme avant.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Jordan Guitton.
- Jordan Guitton: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre délégué
chargé des Transports.
Galère quotidienne, ou encore
allers et retours, nous avons
cumulé des heures de retard.
Voici le quotidien de millions de
personnes qui utilisent les
transports en commun.
Stress, fatigue, retards pour
aller travailler, sans évoquer
l'insécurité.
Les Français sont obligés
d'utiliser un service où les
retards et les suppressions
s'accumulent.
Les prix ne font que monter, comme
le pass Navigo, le ticket de métro
ou bientôt les TGV.
Cette situation n'est plus
tenable.
Entre nos concitoyens de la France
urbaine qui utilisent des
transports en commun dégradés et
les oubliés de la France rurale
qui ne peuvent plus aller
travailler, la politique de
transport du gouvernement continue
de s'effondrer, depuis de
nombreuses années.
Comme dans beaucoup d'autres
domaines, la France perd sa place
de pionnière au profit d'une
gestion de crise permanente, que
même les cabinets de conseil
n'arrivent plus à gérer.
Emmanuel Macron fuit sa
responsabilité en annonçant un
grand plan de RER dans les
métropoles dans 10 ans, au lieu de
faire un grand plan maintenant.
Les Français ne veulent pas un
président sur Internet, avec une
vision parisienne, mais un
président qui facilite leur
quotidien avec une vision
nationale.
Mes questions sont simples.
Que comptez-vous faire pour
redonner aux Français un service
public de qualité avec des
transports en commun de qualité?
Quand allez-vous augmenter la
fréquence des dessertes aux heures
de pointe?
Allez-vous augmenter la qualité et
non le prix du service public?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Monsieur le
député Guitton, c'est précisément
un plan complet, national, pas
uniquement centré sur
l'Ile-de-France, que nous allons
présenter.
Une méthode, qui est celle que
nous avons décrite depuis des
mois.
La présentation par le comité des
infrastructures, après le Tour de
France, qui a commencé il y a
plusieurs mois, de toutes les
infrastructures dans les 13
régions métropolitaines et
au-delà.
Ce plan va s'appuyer sur des
investissements massifs sur le
ferroviaire.
C'est bien entendu la pierre
angulaire de la planification
écologique qui sera déclinée par
la Première ministre.
Des dizaines de milliards d'euros,
avec l'accent qui sera mis sur la
régénération des transports du
quotidien et des lignes.
Nous avons depuis cinq ans
augmenté les moyens que nous y
consacrons.
Il faut encore les augmenter avec
certains sujets comme les postes
de signalisation automatiques.
En parallèle, à côté de ce
dispositif, le président de la
République a dévoilé un des
éléments socle de ce projet que
sont les RER métropolitains sur
lesquels nous travaillons depuis
plusieurs mois.
A partir d'une idée: les
transports représentent 30% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
La voiture individuelle représente
60%.
Le train, pour 10% des voyageurs,
et 9% des marchandises
transportées, c'est très peu.
Augmenter cette part, ça nécessite
d'aller investir là où les
Français vivent.
Nous allons réunir les territoires
au début d'année pour leur
préciser la hauteur de la
contribution de l'Etat.
Ca concernera 10 millions de
Français qui vivent dans ces zones
denses et dans lesquelles nous
interviendrons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Jordan Guitton?
- Jordan Guitton: Merci.
Je vous invite à reprendre les
transports en commun et à vivre la
galère des Français au quotidien.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
ministre?
- Christophe Béchu: Merci pour
votre réponse de politicien.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Francis Dubois.
- Francis Dubois: Madame la
présidente, ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre de
l'Economie.
Monsieur le ministre, un
rassemblement historique se tient
à proximité de l'Assemblée
nationale, organisé à l'initiative
des artisans bouchers charcutiers.
Ils sont venus de la France
entière pour manifester leur
désarroi.
Ces artisans n'ont pas la culture
de la manifestation.
Cela fait 20 ans que la profession
n'a pas manifesté depuis la crise
de la vache folle.
Ils subissent la hausse des prix
de l'énergie.
Toutes les femmes et les hommes du
secteur appellent à réagir.
Le gouvernement n'a pas anticipé
les conséquences économiques et
sociales dramatiques imposées par
la crise énergétique.
Si le gouvernement ne prend pas sa
responsabilité, nous assisterons
collectivement à la mort de
nombreuses entreprises.
Les dispositifs actuels ne
répondent pas aux réalités de
terrain.
40% des entreprises se trouvent
dans une zone blanche et ne
peuvent bénéficier du bouclier
tarifaire.
La mesure de l'amortisseur
électrique prévu pour 2023 est
insuffisante.
La tarification est en hausse de
près de 400%.
Les mesures pour octobre et
décembre ne couvriront qu'une
partie de l'augmentation.
Elles sont inadaptées.
Pour ces artisans, les
augmentations du prix de
l'électricité viendront
pratiquement baisser leurs
résultats, et leur capacité à
rembourser les emprunts.
Qui plus est, dans un contexte où
les prix des matières premières
augmentent.
Sans compter les difficultés de
recrutement dans la filière, c'est
une profession à bout de souffle
et en danger qui manifeste.
Pouvez-vous vous engager à prendre
des mesures efficaces pour
protéger nos artisans et TPE,
maillons forts du lien social, en
zones rurales?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Olivia Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député Dubois, face à
la hausse des prix de l'énergie,
le gouvernement agit et continuera
d'agir.
Premièrement, nous avons un
bouclier tarifaire qui couvre la
moitié de nos TPE, au prix du
bouclier tarifaire.
Nous avons réouvert le dispositif,
le guichet qui permet à nos
artisans boulangers, bouchers et
bien d'autres, d'être aidés, avec
un RIB et deux factures d'énergie
sur 2022, dès lors que ça
représente une partie de leur
chiffre d'affaires 2021.
A partir de 2023, il n'y aura rien
à faire pour pouvoir bénéficier
d'une prise en charge, qui se fera
à 50% de la part énergie de nos
artisans, bouchers, boulangers.
Vous avez posé votre question avec
un vrai engagement et un sens des
responsabilités à l'endroit des
artisans.
Vendredi, j'étais avec les
boulangers.
Demain, je serai avec les
bouchers.
Je ne suis pas du genre à me
défiler.
Nous avons leurs factures en main.
Nous sommes en train de regarder
s'il faut peut-être adapter le
dispositif.
Il faut que le gouvernement prenne
ses responsabilités.
Le gouvernement les prendra et il
accompagnera les artisans.
S'il faut faire un peu plus, nous
le feront.
Avant de dire qu'il faut faire
plus, je sais que vous êtes de
bonne foi, éprouvons déjà les
dispositifs mis en oeuvre.
Il faut tester ce qui est mis en
place.
Il y a 10 milliards d'euros sur la
table.
Nous avons toujours pris nos
responsabilités.
S'il faut plus, nous ferons plus.
Essayons déjà d'obtenir les aides
en place sur Internet.
Si, contrairement à d'autres, vous
êtes ici pour accompagner les
artisans, donnez-leur ces
informations.
Dites-moi si ça ne suffit pas et
nous ferons plus.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Romain Daubié.
- Romain Daubié: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de l'Economie.
La simplification administrative
pour les particuliers ou pour les
entreprises doit être un objectif
pour tous.
Les formalités administratives
pèsent sur l'activité de nos
entreprises, en particulier les
TPE et les PME.
Pour faciliter la création et le
développement des entreprises de
la majorité à décider, à travers
une loi de mai 2019, de rassembler
les réseaux de fonds des
entreprises à travers un guichet
unique.
Il doit permettre à toutes les
entreprises de déclarer en ligne
toutes les formalités.
Création, modification, dépôt de
compte, tout peut se faire en
ligne sur un même site, facilitant
la vie des entrepreneurs.
Ce guichet deviendra obligatoire à
compter du 1er janvier prochain.
Pour encourager la transition, il
est accessible depuis le 1er avril
2021.
Force est de constater qu'à
quelques semaines de l'échéance,
le site actuel n'est pas
satisfaisant.
Certaines entreprises ne sont pas
reconnues.
Le site demande des documents qui
ne correspondent pas à la forme
juridique de l'entreprise.
Cela empêche les entrepreneurs de
réaliser les formalités.
Le guichet unique ne semble pas en
mesure de remplacer le système
existant.
Il semble que plutôt que
d'accélérer la création, ce
guichet ralentit ces démarches, et
que nous nous inquiétons sur le
lancement trop précoce d'un outil
inabouti.
Monsieur le ministre, pensez-vous
que les améliorations nécessaires
pourront être apportées d'ici le
1er janvier pour garantir aux
usagers un système efficace?
Ne faut-il pas décaler sa mise en
place d'au moins six mois?
Une coexistence des guichets
physiques et du guichet unique ne
peut-elle pas être prolongée?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Olivia Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci, monsieur
Daubié.
Je me permettrai de répondre aussi
au président qui m'a déjà
sollicité sur le guichet aux
entreprises.
Vous avez dit que les formalités
pèsent sur les entreprises.
Je dirais même qu'elles pèsent sur
le moral des entrepreneurs et sur
leur marge brute.
Le temps d'un entrepreneur, c'est
du temps et de l'argent.
Combien de nos entrepreneurs ont
été découragés par ces formalités
souvent chronophages?
Ce n'est pas un hasard si la loi
que nous avons été nombreux à
voter lors de la précédente
mandature a effectivement mis en
oeuvre un guichet unique dont
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs ont rêvé
pour créer, transmettre, changer
son adresse, changer de statut,
changer son immatriculation...
C'était un parcours du combattant.
C'est un changement de culture
majeure.
C'est un projet majeur.
Deux tiers des formalités sont au
format papier.
C'est un projet d'ampleur.
Il faut une préparation d'ampleur.
Si je ne sous-estime pas le
changement de culture, je peux
vous dire à quel point, dans notre
ministère, nous sommes mobilisés.
Tous les acteurs impliqués font
des suivis quotidiens.
Nous avons prévu, comme tout
nouveau service, de mettre en
place une procédure de secours
pour les premiers mois de l'année
2023.
Je veux aussi vous rassurer en
vous disant que nous avons mis en
place un système d'assistance en
ligne, aussi au téléphone, pour
les premiers pas des entrepreneurs
qui pourraient être déstabilisés
par ce nouveau guichet.
Le temps est terminé.
Notre bureau est ouvert.
Nous sommes vigilants.
On est très vigilants.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Mathilde Hignet.
- Mathilde Hignet: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur Marc Fesneau.
Les Français sont pris à la gorge
depuis plusieurs mois.
Ils angoissent dans l'attente des
factures d'énergie et ne
remplissent plus leur caddie.
La baisse du pouvoir d'achat des
ménages les contraint à s'orienter
vers des produits moins chers et
de moins bonne qualité.
Vous refusez d'indexer les
salaires sur l'inflation.
Vous refusez de bloquer les prix
de l'énergie.
Comment voulez-vous que les
Français aient les moyens de
privilégier les produits de
qualité issus de l'agriculture
durable?
Une situation qui menace des
paysannes et des paysans français,
qui ont fait l'effort de la
transition vers des pratiques plus
respectueuses de l'environnement,
des animaux et de l'humain.
Certains groupes industriels
freinent la conversion de leurs
producteurs, déclassent les
volumes de production ou encore,
payent moins bien les produits bio
que les produits conventionnels.
Après plusieurs années de
croissance de la filière bio, elle
traverse une véritable crise.
Pour les éleveurs de porcs bio,
les ventes ont reculé.
Une crise qui affecte les magasins
bio.
Après avoir encaissé un recul de
10%, un réseau a été placé en
redressement judiciaire, menaçant
204 emplois.
Si la grande distribution se
détourne de la filière bio, que
reste-t-il aux coproducteurs?
Pour certains, 70% de leurs
débouchés risquent de disparaître.
Il y a la multiplication des
labels.
Le consommateur perd confiance et
ne s'y retrouve plus.
Je le comprends.
Que comptez-vous faire pour
soutenir les paysans et les
paysannes en agriculture bio ou en
appellation d'origine protégée, et
rendre accessible au consommateur
une alimentation plus saine et de
meilleure qualité?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Marc Fesneau.
- Marc Fesneau: Madame la députée,
plusieurs réponses à la question
que vous posez.
D'abord, les faits.
La surface en bio a doublé entre
2007 et 2022 pour atteindre
presque 3 milliards d'hectares.
La France est la première surface
convertie en bio de l'Union
Européenne.
Nous faisons, au travers de la
politique agricole commune, une
augmentation de plus de 30% des
crédits qui vont être alloués à la
conversion en bio.
Ce que nous faisons aussi, et ce
que nous avons fait, dans le cadre
du plan de relance, c'est faire en
sorte de mieux accompagner les
agriculteurs bio...
Quatrième élément: le crédit impôt
bio, qui permet aux agriculteurs
biologiques de maintenir leur
activité.
Nous sommes passés à 109 millions
d'euros.
Nous avons un sujet structurel et
conjoncturel.
Le premier, c'est l'inflation qui
pèse sur les ménages.
Nous avons une inflation tout de
même plus basse que d'autres.
Il y a pourtant une dégradation
dans les choix des consommateurs.
Nous avons besoin de travailler
sur ce sujet.
Nous avons un sujet structurel,
c'est le fait que l'offre doit
être au rendez-vous.
Nous avions une croissance à deux
chiffres sur les produits bio.
Elle a peut-être atteint sa
limite.
Il faut travailler sur la demande,
pour faire en sorte que dans une
stratégie de communication, nous
puissions montrer les vertus de
l'agriculteur biologique dans le
modèle agricole français.
Vous me permettrez de dire qu'il
faut arrêter d'opposer toutes les
démarches et les labels.
Il faut respecter l'ensemble des
producteurs et faire en sorte que
chacun puisse trouver sa place en
termes de rémunération.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur le président André
Chassaigne.
- André Chassaigne: Madame la
Première ministre, ma question
concerne les territoires les plus
pauvres de la République, dans
lesquels la crise actuelle a des
effets démultipliés.
Dans les outre-mer, la vie n'est
plus seulement chère, elle est
hors de prix.
Tout augmente, aucun secteur n'est
épargné.
Déjà hors normes, la grande
pauvreté fait des ravages.
Au cri d'alarme et de souffrance
de nos concitoyens, le
gouvernement a répondu par ce
qu'il appelle un système qui ne
cesse d'être différé.
Cet épisode révèle le manque
d'adaptation.
Le même silence se retrouve pour
les énergies renouvelables.
Rien de prévu, alors que les
outre-mer regorgent de
potentialités, de projets...
A-t-on conscience que c'est leur
objectif d'autonomie énergique
qu'on entrave ainsi?
Que dire du mépris de la majorité
qui préfère camper sur des
positions idéologiques plutôt que
de remédier aux déserts médicaux
et au manque de soignants dont
souffre cruellement nos
concitoyens d'outre-mer?
Madame la Première ministre, il
faut changer de méthode.
Il faut adopter une démarche qui
allie les territoires.
Il faut modifier votre regard et
admettre que ce sont bien les
outre-mer qui font de la France
une puissance maritime, une
puissance spatiale, un joyau
mondial de la biodiversité.
Des trophées qu'il ne suffit pas
de brandir dans les conférences
internationales.
Les femmes et les hommes qui
vivent sur ces terres aspirent au
développement, ce qui implique de
leur donner accès à leur avenir.
Le statu quo n'est plus tenable.
Les vieilles recettes ne font
qu'amplifier la colère qui
grandit.
L'Etat sera-t-il présent à ce
rendez-vous historique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Vous avez
raison, monsieur le président, la
France est riche de ses outre-mer.
Ce sont des territoires d'avenir,
de jeunesse.
Ce sont des territoires à la
biodiversité inestimable.
Ce sont des territoires
déterminants pour notre
souveraineté et pour notre
économie.
Les outre-mer, nous le savons, ce
sont aussi des terres de défis.
Le défi de la vie chère auquel il
nous faut répondre.
Le défi climatique, qui menace les
territoires, le défi de l'emploi
et de l'attractivité, le défi de
la sécurité et de la question
migratoire.
Derrière ce mot de défi, il y a
des attentes.
Il y a de la colère, parfois.
Il y a la situation de la jeunesse
qui attend légitimement des
réponses.
Nous ne détournons pas le regard
de cette réalité.
Avec le ministre de l'Intérieur,
nous sommes déterminés à y
répondre.
Pour répondre sur le pouvoir
d'achat, nous voulons répondre à
l'urgence sur le pouvoir d'achat,
nous avons décidé d'augmenter les
aides sociales.
Nous travaillons à des réponses
structurelles.
Ce que nous mettons en place vise
à mettre en place des opérations
sur les produits de grande
consommation.
Des chartes ont été signées et
d'autres sont en cours de
signature.
Nous augmentons également les
moyens pour nos outre-mer dans le
budget 2023 avec une augmentation
de 10% du budget.
Nous investissons dans tous les
domaines, notamment dans les
domaines qui permettent de lever
les difficultés du quotidien.
Je pense à la distribution de
l'eau en Guadeloupe, ou aux
questions du logement dans
l'ensemble de nos outre-mer.
Nous investissons pour accélérer
la transition écologique.
Nous voulons faire de La Réunion
un territoire pilote pour l'éolien
flottant.
Nous voulons renforcer la
sécurité.
Je pense particulièrement à la
Guyane et à Mayotte aussi.
Il reste beaucoup de chemin à
parcourir.
Vous plaidez pour une nouvelle
méthode.
C'est ce sur quoi nous voulons
travailler.
C'était le sens de la réunion du 7
septembre à l'Elysée autour du
président de la République, suite
à l'appel des élus d'outre-mer.
Le travail a commencé dans un
esprit d'ouverture.
Nous examinerons toutes les
propositions concrètes qui nous
parviendront.
Je réunirai un conseil
interministériel des outre-mer au
printemps prochain, qui suivra la
mise en oeuvre des mesures et leur
résultat concret.
Sur tous ces sujets, nous
souhaitons travailler de concert
avec les parlementaires, et les
élus.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Dominique Potier.
- Dominique Potier: Madame la
Première ministre, le 27 mars
2017, la France adoptait une loi
pionnière dans le monde, la loi
Devoir de vigilance, qui levait le
voile sur les relations entre les
multinationales et leurs filiales.
Cette idée n'a cessé de faire
école dans l'opinion publique.
Nous avons un socle parlementaire
transpartisan.
Nous avons adopté une résolution
le 20 janvier à l'unanimité, dans
cette missive.
Cette loi a progressé en Europe
avec l'adoption par les Pays-Bas
et l'Allemagne d'une loi
équivalente.
Cinq pays suivent la même voie.
En février, un projet de directive
a été proposé par la Commission
européenne.
Vendredi 1er décembre, dans
quelques jours, c'est le conseil
des chefs d'Etat et de
gouvernements qui prendra position
sur la proposition de la
présidence tchèque en vue
d'adopter une directive qui sera
soumise au niveau européen.
Il convient que cette loi soit la
plus forte possible.
Ce n'est pas une loi d'apparence.
C'est une loi pour les enfants des
mines de cobalt et des champs de
cacao.
C'est une loi pour les peuples
d'Amazonie.
C'est une loi pour les ouvriers
dans les camps d'internement
chinois.
Cette loi, pour qu'elle soit
forte, la France doit la porter.
Je vais vous clarifier la position
de la France dans ces négociations
autour de trois questions: le
périmètre.
Celui des entreprises
des banques sont-elles incluses?
Cette question sera-t-elle portée
à travers les donneurs d'ordre?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Monsieur le
député Dominique Potier, l'Europe
est d'abord une communauté de
valeurs.
C'est ce qui en fait un projet
politique et pas seulement
économique.
Cela doit se refléter pleinement
dans les règles que nous
établissons au sein du marché
intérieur ou dans les relations
commerciales avec le reste du
monde.
Les exigences en matière sociale,
en matière environnementale, et
bien sûr concernant les droits
humains, doivent être au coeur des
législations que nous adoptons au
sein de l'Union Européenne.
C'est cette approche qui est au
fondement de la proposition de
directive auprès des entreprises
que la commission a proposée fin
février et qui est en cours de
négociation.
Je le dis sans détour: nous sommes
en faveur de cette directive.
Nous soutenons ce texte car il
favorise un comportement durable
et responsable des entreprises
tout au long de leur chaîne de
valeur mondiale.
Ces règles apportent de la
sécurité juridique aux entreprises
et garantiront une plus grande
transparence pour les
consommateurs et investisseurs.
Nous soutenons ce texte également
car il porte au niveau européen le
combat que nous avons d'abord mené
au niveau national.
Monsieur le député Potier, vous le
savez mieux que quiconque, car
vous êtes à l'origine de la loi
sur le devoir de vigilance qui
porte votre nom et dont notre pays
s'est doté en mars 2017.
La France est pionnière en la
matière grâce à vous.
Seuls trois Etats-membres ont mis
en place les mêmes règles sur le
devoir de vigilance.
Si certaines entreprises ont pris
des initiatives, il faut agir à
plus grand échelle, celle de
l'Union Européenne.
Nous avons fait de ce texte une de
nos priorités.
Le gouvernement reste pleinement
mobilisé.
Nous travaillons sans relâche afin
de parvenir à un texte ambitieux.
Un texte ambitieux, c'est un texte
qui ne transige pas avec les
valeurs sociales,
environnementales et humaines.
C'est un texte efficace qui pose
des règles claires.
Un texte ambitieux, c'est un texte
protecteur qui prend en compte les
risques de concurrence déloyale de
la part des acteurs qui ne
seraient pas soumis aux mêmes
règles.
Forts de notre expérience, nous
aidons pour un cadre de vigilance
opérationnel.
Les discussions menées au sein de
cette assemblée avaient permis de
retrouver cet équilibre dans notre
législation nationale.
Les grandes entreprises ont de
l'influence vis-à-vis de leurs
filiales, fournisseurs et
sous-traitants.
Elles doivent utiliser cette
influence y compris sur leurs
partenaires à l'étranger afin de
contribuer au respect des droits
de l'homme et à la protection de
l'environnement.
Cette ambition doit être la même
dans tous les secteurs d'activité
concernés, sans traitement
spécifique.
Nous sommes évidemment très
attentifs à ce que le futur texte
ne se traduise pas par une baisse
des obligations de vigilance dans
notre pays.
Je compte sur vous pour
sensibiliser vos collègues
européens en faveur d'un système
pleinement équilibré, notamment
sur la prise en compte des
entreprises.
Ce sont ces principes que nous
portons dans les négociations en
cours.
Elles se sont accélérées ces
dernières semaines.
Nous espérons qu'il sera possible
d'arriver à un accord lors du
conseil de compétitivité jeudi
prochain dont le travail
continuera au Parlement européen.
Nous espérons une adoption de ce
texte majeur en 2023.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Clara Chassaniol.
- Clara Chassaniol: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre.
Vous avez présenté une nouvelle
mesure pour les travailleurs de la
fonction publique.
Nous devons beaucoup à notre haute
fonction publique et aux écoles
qui y mènent.
La haute fonction publique a
construit un Etat fort qui permet
de résister aux crises
successives.
Par
manque de diversité, et un manque
d'agilité, pour adapter les
carrières...
Je souhaite souligner les
améliorations apportées.
La suppression de l'ENA, la
nécessité d'apporter un vrai
service de ressources humaines à
la haute fonction publique et
l'adoption de bourses de 4000
euros pour les élèves.
Vous avez tracé de nouvelles
ambitions.
Vous avez mis en place davantage
de mobilité, de reconnaissance des
compétences.
Comment comptez-vous déployer ces
transformations?
Comment faire savoir aux jeunes
pour qu'ils réalisent que ces
administrations et ces carrières
sont fascinantes?
Il faut que nous ayons accès à
tous ces profils.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Stanislas Guerini.
- Stanislas Guerini: Madame la
députée, merci de m'interroger sur
cette nouvelle étape déterminante
de la réforme de la haute fonction
publique qui vient parachever
l'ambition que le président de la
République avait émise lors du
dernier quinquennat.
Les présidents successifs avaient la
volonté de supprimer le classement
de l'ENA.
Ils n'avaient pas pu le faire.
C'est ce gouvernement, cette
majorité, qui sera allé au bout de
ce classement.
Comment expliquer qu'un classement
obtenu à 25 ans venait sceller une
carrière entière dans
l'administration?
Lorsque nous nous sommes engagés
contre toutes les formes de
déterminisme, je crois que tous
les bancs de cet hémicycle
devraient soutenir cette réforme.
Cette réforme, c'est une réforme
d'ambition.
Elle va permettre aux élèves de se
concentrer non pas sur
l'optimisation d'un classement de
sortie, mais de se préparer à une
carrière dans la haute
administration, dans une logique
de professionnalisation.
C'est une réforme d'ambition.
Un autre élément: l'harmonisation
de tous les systèmes
d'administration.
Autour de deux éléments,
l'attractivité et la récompense
des engagements.
J'assume de porter cette réforme
avec une rémunération variable à
hauteur de 30%.
Ce n'est pas une réforme
uniquement pour la haute fonction
publique.
Lorsqu'on parle de diversité et de
mobilité des carrières, de gestion
par les compétences, nous portons
bien une ambition pour l'ensemble
de la fonction publique dans notre
pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Benjamin Saint-Huile.
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Agriculture, Marc Fesneau.
Cet après-midi, je souhaite vous
parler de l'inquiétude des
agriculteurs qui ont choisi de se
lancer dans la production bio.
Je veux parler en particulier de
la production laitière.
Je viens d'un territoire où
beaucoup d'exploitations ont
décidé de se convertir en bio.
En 2022, nous avons dû faire face
à la question de l'inflation qui
touche les produits bio, qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui, ces produits ne
sont pas ceux qui sont regardés
les premiers par les gens qui sont
attentifs à leur pouvoir d'achat.
Deuxième sujet, la sécheresse qui
impacte nos agriculteurs.
La question qui revient
systématiquement dans les
discussions avec les agriculteurs
de mon territoire, c'est que
devons-nous faire?
Le litre de lait est vendu 450
euros en moyenne.
C'est revendu 1310 euros.
L'Etat a accompagné la conversion
vers le bio pour atteindre les
objectifs européens.
Le territoire que je représente
fait partie des meilleurs élèves
de France.
Les agriculteurs que je croise
aujourd'hui me disent qu'ils
repartent dans le conventionnel
car ils ne gagnent pas leur vie.
Qu'allez-vous faire pour répondre
à cette urgence, à des
agriculteurs qui souffrent et qui
ont été exemplaires dans le choix
de la conversion?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La réponse est
à monsieur Marc Fesneau, ministre
de l'Agriculture.
- Marc Fesneau: Vous avez très
bien décrit la situation.
C'est compliqué pour le lait.
Deuxième sujet, la hausse des
charges.
Il faut d'abord agir sur
l'urgence.
C'est ce que nous avons fait avec
le plan d'aide à l'alimentation
animale.
Cela concernait surtout d'autres
filières d'élevage, mais ça a
permis d'apporter une première
réponse.
Deuxième réponse, le plan
d'allégement des charges que nous
déployons actuellement.
Ca permettra de réduire les
charges dans les exploitations et
d'améliorer la trésorerie.
Troisième élément, les calamités
agricoles.
Nous voulons accélérer le
processus.
Pour les régions qui sont les plus
touchées par la sécheresse, nous
voulons accélérer.
Pour les autres départements, ils
rentreront au printemps.
Souvent, il y a un problème de
trésorerie.
Quatrième élément, c'est de
regarder la grande distribution.
On veut revaloriser le prix du
lait.
Des efforts ont été faits mais pas
assez sur le prix du bio.
On a besoin d'un choc de demandes
sur ces produits.
C'est le travail que nous devons
mener avec les agriculteurs et les
producteurs laitiers.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Je vous
invite à venir travailler avec les
agriculteurs de nos territoires
sur ces sujets.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Frédéric Falcon pour le
groupe Rassemblement National.
- Frédéric Falcon: J'aimerais
rappeler que la France est
championne en Europe pour son
électricité décarbonée.
Notre pays est un exemple en
Europe face à l'Allemagne qui émet
huit fois plus de CO2.
Malgré cela, vous souhaitez suivre
l'échec allemand en développant
les éoliennes.
On se demande comment
l'installation d'éoliennes
résoudrait notre crise
énergétique.
Les 80 éoliennes que vous venez
d'inaugurer au large de
Saint-Nazaire ne produiront que 8
% de la production d'une seule
centrale nucléaire.
Il faudrait installer en mer 13
fois plus d'éoliennes.
On ne peut qu'être effaré de
découvrir le lobby pour la
transition énergétique.
Les principaux membres de ce lobby
sont les producteurs d'éoliennes
en Allemagne.
Un lobby des éoliennes est arrivé
en France.
Il a même comme membre Greenpeace.
Quelles sont les actions que vous
allez mettre en oeuvre pour
expulser de votre ministère un
organisme de lobbying qui n'y a
pas sa place?
Comment lutter contre
l'infiltration de nos institutions
par le lobby antinucléaire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Agnès Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Monsieur
le député Frédéric Falcon, je
voudrais d'abord préciser une
chose.
La loi que nous portons en ce
moment pour l'accélération des
énergies renouvelables porte sur
l'ensemble des énergies
renouvelables.
Elle porte sur la géothermie, le
biogaz, le photovoltaïque
électrique et thermique, et elle
porte effectivement aussi sur les
éoliennes, comme elle porte sur la
biomasse.
Contrairement à ce que vous dites,
aujourd'hui, notre énergie est aux
deux tiers fossile.
Le nucléaire ne pèse que 20% de
notre consommation finale
d'énergie.
C'est une réalité.
La deuxième réalité, mais vous
l'avez en tête, c'est que dans le
mouvement de relance des énergie
nucléaires que nous avons entamé
avec ce gouvernement et cette
majorité, ce mouvement va prendre
au minimum 15 ans pour livrer son
premier réacteur EPR.
Que faisons-nous entre les deux?
Le contexte c'est que les Français
souffrent de payer très cher les
énergies renouvelables.
Les entreprises souffrent de perte
de compétitivité.
Nous avons choisi la voie de
l'action pour accélérer sur les
énergies renouvelables.
Nous avons une responsabilité
environnementale et nous avons une
responsabilité devant les Français
de sécuriser le déploiement de
nouvelles énergies sur notre
territoire.
- Frédéric Falcon: Vous n'avez pas
répondu sur la place de ce lobby
dans votre ministère.
Il n'y a pas de surprise.
Le macronisme, c'est l'art de la
trahison.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher:
Le Rassemblement National,
c'est de mauvaises solutions
à de vrais
problèmes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Anne-Cécile Violland.
- Anne-Cécile Violland: Ce
week-end, en circonscription, je
reçois de nombreuses
interpellations sur des situations
de Covid long.
Une femme me racontait son Covid
de 32 mois.
Les témoignages se multiplient.
D'après les premiers chiffres de
Santé publique France, plus de 10
millions d'adultes français
souffrent de cette affection de
longue durée caractérisée par des
séquelles psychologiques,
neurologiques, cardio-vasculaires
ou encore rénales.
Elle peut toucher n'importe quel
citoyen ayant contracté le Covid.
Il s'agit de troubles mal connus
et peu étudiés.
De trop nombreux français se
retrouvent ainsi dans des
situations non reconnues par
l'administration.
Ils entament des parcours de soins
non remboursés.
L'association Covid Long France
nous interpelle sur la mauvaise
compréhension de la maladie au
sein des services de la Caisse
d'Assurance Maladie, tout comme
par la médecine de travail ou la
médecine de ville.
Les conséquences sur la santé des
Français sont majeures.
Il est indispensable de mieux le
prendre en compte en développant
l'accès aux lieux d'écoute.
Le Parlement a voté une loi visant
à la création d'une plate-forme de
référencement et de prise en
charge des maladies chroniques du
Covid.
Cependant, il est urgent pour des
millions de nos compatriotes
d'accélérer la concertation et la
parution des décrets
d'application.
De plus, alors que de nombreuses
revues scientifiques sont parues
depuis deux ans, la recherche
française manque d'investissement,
notamment pour entamer des essais
thérapeutiques demandés par des
patients souffrant de Covid long.
Ces Français sont dans
l'incapacité de poursuivre leur
activité professionnelle.
Quelles réponses pouvons-nous
faire à ces millions de Français?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Agnès Firmin Le Bodo.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo: Madame la
députée Anne-Cécile Violland, deux
ans et demi après le début de la
crise sanitaire, le parcours du
combattant n'en finit pas pour les
malades du Covid long.
C'est pour cela que ce sujet est
un enjeu majeur pour le ministère.
Le docteur Dominique Martin a été
confirmé dans sa mission avec
toutes les administrations du
ministère.
Six mois après la parution de la
feuille de route, nous voulons
avancer vite.
Nous allons réunir l'ensemble des
parties prenantes concernées pour
un point d'étape.
Nous allons mettre en place la
plate-forme dont vous parliez.
Ce sujet figure dans la lettre de
mission.
Néanmoins, nous pouvons aussi dire
que des actions sont mises en
oeuvre.
Il faut peut-être le faire savoir.
Des informations sont mises à
disposition sur le Covid long.
Notamment sur le site de la CNAM.
Les cellules d'appui et de
coordination post-Covid ont été
généralisées dans les territoires.
L'information des médecins a été
renforcée.
Un outil a aussi été développé par
la CNAM afin de faciliter le
travail du médecin traitant en
recueillant les données médicales
du patient de manière structurée.
Des vidéos ont été mises en ligne
cet été.
Les choses avancent et les malades
ne sont plus laissés sans réponse.
Mais leur nombre et la diversité
des formes dont ils souffrent
doivent nous pousser à accélérer
encore le processus.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Dino Cinieri pour Les
Républicains.
- Dino Cinieri: Madame la Première
ministre, jeudi dernier, votre
majorité minoritaire a bloqué le
débat sur la réintégration des
soignants non-vaccinés contre le
Covid-19.
Ce combat était pourtant
important.
Ce débat est d'autant plus
légitime que la France est l'un
des derniers pays en Europe à
n'avoir toujours pas réintégré les
soignants non-vaccinés.
Même la Grèce va les réintégrer.
La suspension de nos personnels de
santé devait être temporaire.
Pourtant, vous vous y opposez
toujours.
Nous vous proposions pourtant un
protocole.
Près de 3000 infirmiers et
aides-soignants sont suspendus
depuis plus d'un an sans salaire
ni indemnisation de chômage.
Pendant ce temps, les hôpitaux
font face à un manque criant de
soignants.
Des enfants se retrouvent sans
suivi.
Les établissements médico-sociaux
font également face à des
difficultés majeures du fait d'un
manque d'effectif.
Cela accentue la quantité de
travail des soignants présents et
cela affaiblit la qualité de la
prise en charge et des soins
prodigués.
Les députés Républicains
n'acceptent pas la mise au ban de
nos soignants.
Nous vous demandons donc de
réintégrer sans délai tous les
soignants que nous avons applaudis
durant des mois à 20h.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Agnès
Firmin Le Bodo.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo: Monsieur
le député Dino Cinieri, je tiens
d'abord à rappeler l'importance
essentielle de la vaccination.
C'est grâce à elle que nous avons
pu retrouver une vie normale et
mieux protéger les plus fragiles
d'entre nous.
Je rappelle que les campagnes
hivernales de vaccination contre
la grippe et le Covid ont débuté.
J'invite nos concitoyens les plus
fragiles à se vacciner contre ces
deux maladies.
J'espère que vous pourrez être en
relais de ce message.
La vaccination protège contre les
formes graves de ces deux virus.
Le principe de l'obligation
vaccinale a été voté par le
Parlement dans le cadre de la loi
du 5 août 2021 relative à la
gestion de la crise sanitaire.
Ce principe a été validé par le
Conseil constitutionnel.
Les professionnels de santé nous
disent qu'ils sont dans la
majorité opposés au retour de
leurs collègues qui n'ont pas joué
le jeu de la vaccination.
Et ce, alors qu'ils sont les
premières victimes de l'absence
des soignants dans les
établissements de santé.
Le gouvernement est
particulièrement attentif à la
situation, avec une attention
particulière pour les outre-mer.
La vaccination protège les
systèmes de santé et garantit un
accès aux soins pour tous.
Nous n'irons pas à l'encontre des
autorités scientifiques.
La Haute autorité se prononcera
sur la réactualisation de la
vaccination des professionnels de
santé.
Vous faisiez allusion au protocole
mis en place.
Votre groupe disait qu'il était
inefficace.
- Dino Cinieri: Tous les soignants
méritent la reconnaissance de la
nation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Christine Arrighi.
- Christine Arrighi: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre délégué
chargé des Transports, qui n'est
pas là.
Nous n'avons plus d'autres choix
que des réponses rapides et
coordonnées aux différentes crises
auxquelles nous faisons face.
La question des mobilités devient
un enjeu de plus en plus
stratégique, en particulier pour
les populations les plus
précaires.
Il faut accompagner le déploiement
des zones à faible émission.
Dans l'agglomération toulousaine,
75% des habitants sont en dehors
de l'hyper centre.
Ils sont aujourd'hui obligés
d'utiliser leur voiture car ils ne
disposent pas d'un transport en
commun adapté.
Le RER constitue donc une réponse
efficace à cet enjeu, bien que la
SNCF travaille depuis longtemps
sur le concept de service express
métropolitain.
Le soutien financier et concret de
l'Etat tarde à se faire sentir.
Le groupe écologiste a déposé un
amendement au projet de loi de
finances en faveur notamment du
financement des RER
métropolitains, amendement numéro
912, rejeté en commission des
finances et non discuté en séance
suite au recours du 49.3.
Le président de la République
semble soudain découvrir
l'importance des services express
métropolitains.
Le gouvernement s'engage dans un
grand plan de renouvellement
étatique des transports...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
députée, je n'ai aucun doute sur
le fait que Clément Beaune aurait
adoré vous répondre cet
après-midi.
Il est dans le Loiret.
Dans cet hémicycle, le soir où
vous avez
appelez de vos voeux les dépenses
pour les infrastructures
ferroviaires, je vous ai dit que
nous allions proposer un plan
cohérent ensemble.
Je m'aperçois que vous préférez le
silence quand vous posez la
question et le brouhaha quand je
vous réponds.
Vous avez félicité le président de
la République.
Je pense que cela lui va droit au
coeur.
Le gouvernement travaille à
présenter un projet qui soit
cohérent et global.
Le financement de la
généralisation des RER jusqu'en
2040.
Nous parlons de plusieurs dizaines
de milliards d'euros
d'investissements ferroviaires.
Nous voulons répondre aux attentes
des territoires.
Nous voulons en effet faire en
sorte de proposer des alternatives
à la voiture, et en particulier
aux voitures polluantes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Farida
Amrani pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Farida Amrani: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre délégué en
charge des Transports.
Le président de la République a
annoncé des projets de RER dans 10
métropoles françaises.
Ile-de-France mobilités s'apprête
à augmenter le prix du pass
Navigo.
Le service public francilien n'a
jamais été aussi dégradé.
Les conditions de transport sont
insupportables.
Certains trains sont supprimés,
d'autres retardés.
Il y a une pénurie de conducteurs.
Chaque jour en Ile-de-France, près
de 10 millions de déplacements
sont impactés par ces
dysfonctionnements.
La faute au désengagement
financier de l'Etat et à la
responsabilité de la région
Ile-de-France.
Le service public est bradé depuis
plusieurs années.
Pas un jour sans incident sur la
ligne du RER B empruntée par des
milliers d'habitants de ma
circonscription.
Et c'est pareil sur l'ensemble du
réseau.
Le RER, ce n'est pas seulement à
Paris, selon le président Macron.
Pour le moment, c'est plutôt
bloqué à la gare.
Il est temps de garantir un
service public digne de ce nom, un
service public qui répondra aux
attentes et aux enjeux climatiques
et économiques de notre pays.
Plutôt que de vous renvoyer la
balle avec Valérie Pécresse!
Nous espérons que vous réussirez à
convaincre votre collègue en
charge des comptes publics de
financer les annonces du
président.
Plus de 3 milliards d'euros en
faveur du transport ont été
supprimés par le 49.3.
Comment comptez-vous agir pour que
les transports soient enfin à la
hauteur des besoins?
Quand Clément Beaune aura-t-il
autant d'ambition pour le
transport public que pour sa
carrière?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
députée, d'abord, soyons humbles.
Notre réseau nécessite
effectivement des surplus de
crédit en régénération, mais
l'humilité vaut sur tous les
bancs.
Ce n'est pas le fruit de quelques
mois de sous-investissement.
C'est au début des années 80 que
les crédits que nous avons
commencé à consacrer à la
régénération des réseaux ont cessé
d'être à la hauteur de l'entretien
de nos réseaux.
Le gouvernement dont nous sommes
les continuateurs a, au cours du
dernier quinquennat, augmenté les
crédits à la régénération.
6,3 milliards d'euros seront
consacrés au ferroviaire pour
l'année 2023.
C'est bien plus que la décennie
précédente.
Vous plaidez pour qu'on présente
un plan ferroviaire ambitieux.
Je viens déjà de répondre deux
fois à cette question.
C'est dans le cadre de la
planification écologique.
Le moment venu, vous trouverez des
choses à redire.
Vous ne supportez pas que d'autres
mettent en oeuvre la planification
écologique dont vous aimeriez
avoir le monopole.
Sur la question du RER, avec les
investissements sur les RER, il y
a des sujets sur lesquels nous
avançons.
Mais là aussi, vous préférez
pointer la galère.
Vous préférez être dans
l'incantation plutôt que l'action.
L'action, c'est le plan que nous
bâtissons.
C'est la planification écologique
qui est portée par notre
gouvernement.
Mais vous voulez rester dans
l'outrance.
- Farida Amrani: Je vous invite à
emprunter à mes côtés dès demain
le RER et on pourra en reparler
ensemble.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Jean-Luc Fugit pour le
groupe Renaissance.
- Jean-Luc Fugit: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre de
l'Economie et des Finances.
La semaine dernière, vous avez
présidé un conseil pour parler de
l'avenir spatial européen.
L'Agence spatiale européenne a
annoncé la sélection d'une
astronaute française dans la
nouvelle promotion.
Elle sera la deuxième femme
astronaute française.
C'est une fierté pour la France.
Le Parlement suit de près les
questions spatiales.
Début novembre, nous avons
auditionné les principaux acteurs
du spatial français.
Notamment les grands groupes
industriels
Ariane et Airbus.
De ces échanges, il ressort que
face à la concurrence américaine
et chinoise, une Europe souveraine
doit conserver un accès à l'espace
par la Guyane.
Cette souveraineté a un coût dont
nous ne pourrons pas faire
l'économie.
Les dernières annonces sont
rassurantes mais le calendrier
doit être précisé.
Face à l'urgence climatique,
l'observation de la Terre par
satellite s'avère cruciale.
L'Europe doit être capable de
mesurer ses propres émissions de
gaz à effet de serre, mais aussi
les émissions des autres pays.
Monsieur le ministre, au vu de ces
nombreux enjeux, pouvez-vous nous
présenter les décisions majeures
prises au niveau européen la
semaine dernière et nous indiquer
à quelle hauteur se situe
l'ambition française pour répondre
à ces défis majeurs?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Roland Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Merci pour cette
question sur un sujet qui vous
mobilise depuis longtemps.
Je voudrais d'abord commencer par
saluer nos deux spationautes qui
ont été sélectionnés.
La semaine dernière, c'était la
semaine de l'industrie.
Nous avons décidé de mettre en
avant la place des jeunes filles
françaises dans l'industrie
française.
Je suis donc très fier de
féliciter notre nouvel astronaute.
J'espère qu'elle pourra elle aussi
conquérir l'espace.
Elle vient de Bourgogne.
Bruno Le Maire présidait la
conférence ministérielle sur
l'Agence européenne spatiale la
semaine dernière.
Ca été l'occasion de renforcer et
d'affirmer à nouveau l'engagement
de la France et de l'Europe sur
les programmes européens spatiaux.
C'est un très bel engagement
collectif de l'Europe.
Cela nous conduit à voter ensemble
un budget d'investissement global
de 17 milliards d'euros sur trois
ans.
Le budget fourni par la France
sera en hausse par rapport à 2019.
C'est important de souligner que
la France reste le premier pays
contributeur en Europe au
programme européen spatial.
9 milliards d'euros sont consacrés
au secteur spatial dans les trois
prochaines années,
comme annoncé par la Première
ministre.
Deux objectifs principaux:
renforcer l'autonomie européenne
dans le secteur spatial.
Deuxième point, améliorer la
connaissance du changement
climatique à travers le
financement de programmes
d'observation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La séance est
suspendue.